last night the Prime Minister was  admitted to hospital for tests following  advice from his doctor this was a  precautionary step because he continues  to have persistent coronavirus symptoms  ten days after first having tested  positive for the virus I can tell you  that PM had a comfortable night in  hospital and he's in good spirits he's  still in hospital under observation he's  been given regular updates on  developments and he continues to lead  the government I can reassure the  British people that the government  remains united in a single overriding  priority which is to defeat the corona  virus and see this nation through the  challenge ahead